[Music]
his tears today he's going to talk about
his work in the real world thanks
everybody and thanks Simon's
for inviting me here Nicole for giving
me an opportunity to present Sofia is a
online technology for buying and selling
homes and it basically implements many
of the theorems many of the principles
in economics we learn in in theoretical
community and it's an attempt to
actually take some of those and put them
into practice so let me start with the
consumer problem like what consumers are
looking for so how many peoples are
bought or sold homes
quite a few many people who are students
will eventually buy so what do customers
look for in this domain so customers
look for three things according to our
interview with their mari
our observation they look for a first
complete user experience it's a
sophisticated transaction when you are
buying or selling homes 10 different
entity come together to make it that
transaction happens it's very much like
M&A in corporate world there are lawyers
involved there escrow company they are
not valid companies there are bankers
involved who perform their own due
diligence so there's a lot of complexity
there and every buyer and sellers feel
that you know no matter what the
situation is there is somebody to answer
my question so it has to be complete
user
variance then the next thing they look
for is certainty that whatever action
they are doing let's say I and you agree
to do a transaction I'm selling my home
to you I would love to have complete
certainty because I might be moving from
Seattle to New York and the last thing I
want is so then you're on the last woman
I'm told my home is not sold so they
look for certainty and they are willing
to pay quite a bit for that and the
third thing of course everybody looks
for best pricing affordable t they want
to make sure that the entire transaction
is within certain cost so what we have
done traditionally the industry the
brokerage they have done very good job
in providing complete user experience
you will not find a real estate agent
who would say no I would leave you in
between everybody will say you know we
take care of you then there are this
industry in last few years is making
innovation in two directions so one is
the certainty like there are companies
which are coming up from Bay Area's not
far from here what they do is they buy
the home from you if your homes are at
the buy the home from you at your choice
at your convenience and then it's their
responsibility to sell it back you're
not going to live in that home
themselves so they will sell it back to
the buyers and for that they take about
15% cut so they will pay you 85% of your
home value more or less and then on the
right hand side there are tech enabled
brokerages I don't know how much how
many of you have heard name of like red
fin or purple brakes in Europe so what
they have done is they have been used
the e-commerce to try to or or Internet
to say you try to make the transaction
more efficient but they don't provide
the
certainty so you are on your own if
something goes wrong in the translation
so what do actually fara has done is
using some of the principles which I
will talk about we provide all these
three things simultaneously you get
complete user experience on our website
it's pretty affordable and it's certain
that things happens so we follow the
ecommerce model the left-hand side so
this is the general industry landscape
like what the traditional industry is
doing what other players are doing so we
do e-commerce a transaction can cost as
little as half percent then the
traditional brokers which are five to
six percent on a transaction then there
is a tech enabled brokers we just talked
about Redfin or compass they cost about
four to six percent of the transaction
but they don't provide certainty the
second column provides complete user
experience no affordability no certainty
this next column provides a little bit
of affordability and complete user
experience and they provide complete
certainty and complete user experience
and they are sort of flat free brokers
they provide basically affordability
here and these are that sometimes people
confuse Mozilla and Trulia what they are
doing they are the media company they
are just advertisers they don't
participate in in a transaction Zillow
and Trulia with real state is the same
thing let's say as Yahoo News with the
news that is the publishers of the data
so before I continue the let me tell you
like we have sold thousands plus homes
so the data I will present comes from
very statistically significant number
total our average home is about half a
million so that gives you half a billion
plus and we have done close to six
million dollar revenue it's a slightly
lower slide oldest like sorry and PDX
five and a half million
so here the theory is very powerful
because you can see the performance so
among all these startups I know of for
each million dollar of capital raised we
have done the most amount of
transactions so we have done 200 plus
transactions for each $1,000,000 while
if you look for other companies I some
of them I mentioned they are abuse Lea
at a forty or fifty transactions for
each million dollars of race so that's a
shows the police strong performance now
let's start some problem here
so why the transaction are expensive why
they are the way they are so real estate
transactions are risky that's and so it
is a lot of money for most people it is
their lifetime of savings and when
somebody's let's say moving from Seattle
to New York for a job change want to
sell the home then that person is taking
two kinds of risk in any kind of sales
you take two kind of risk when is the
market risk market risk means you need
to find a buyer who is within within
your time constraint who is willing to
pay a market price for your home okay
that's a market risk and second risk you
take even if you found a buyer you have
a performance risk whether the buyer
will be able to perform well whether the
buyer will eventually
be willing to sorry able to purchase the
home there are a lot of uncertainty
behind that point so every industry we
know are risk-averse consumers are in
stores so for example if you were trying
to sell shoes online and most people
would not buy shoes online because they
want to walk a few steps but then
there's the company suppose they came
like they deduced a risk they say okay
if the shoes doesn't fit just put it in
the box outside of your home we will
send a pickup UPS pick up guy and that
person will pick up the shoes so no risk
to you no hassle no there's no cost and
then people started buying shoes online
so but this industry has not reduced
that is so far so there are three
approaches one is traditional approach
so in traditional approach you go to a
broker the dress is important usually
the broker you go to is your friend a
friend of a friend at the most it's a
one or two degree from you and so what
the broker will do is well negotiate the
risk transfer with the other side
they're not going to reduce the
performance risk they will just
negotiate so this is how the the brokers
do but here that since the risk is
involved there is no mathematical
definition of risk which is universally
accepted and everybody has a different
profile in their heart whether they are
discovers risk taker etc so when the
risk is involved the trust is really
important so this is how in the Indian
United States there are two brokers but
we call them and what their industry
doors are actually opposite so the
broker we've called them buyer's agent
practically if the industry name is
selling agent the buyer's agent
his job is not to provide services to
the buyers that it's legally fiduciary
duty mentioned but the incentives are
aligned the the job of and that's how
the industry call them industry uses the
terms selling broker because their job
is to sell the home to you they will say
whatever they need to tell you so that
you buy the home so you're not trying
let's say if there's something wrong
they may not be me observe it they may
not try to say hey this is not a good
home for you I will find you another
home don't worry this is not a good time
to buy the home prices are going to fall
late next year they will never say that
because they are selling broker they
will say things whatever requires to
sell the home a similarly the listing
agent he many people think I have a good
listing agent he can sell my home for a
high price most of us think that the
listing agent is not a selling agent the
roles are reversed as I said listing
agent is not even for the their real
estate organizations most cities have
they have rules against listing broker
talking with the buyers directly so he
cannot influence things so there's a
other innovation we talk about which is
I buyers like open-door buy the home to
resell so this is what they do they buy
the home they resell but in doing so
they are consuming both the risk the
market risk as well as performance risk
so if we believe in efficient market
theory then they can never deduce the
cost of the transaction because nobody
can predict the market maybe housing
market is slow they may have a false
belief that hey they can predict but you
cannot predict but the stock market will
be let's say in the next minute whatever
happened in the stock market a minute
happens in a month in real estate market
but the market behavior is is about the
same it just slow so they are trying to
predict what price they can sell it for
the
a lot of technology at the end of the
day they need to maintain a certain
buffer to make profit and that buffer is
also not clear whether it's sustainable
in the market because if you're a buyer
if there are a lot of these companies
you will just go and everybody hey give
me the best - give me the best and then
you will have a winners curse you will
go to that seller so how do they prevent
from winners cars so they prevent
winners curse by not making it easy so
even though they claim that you know you
get an offer online but that offer is
suggesting advertising price the real
offer is made after they visited you
your home and inspected you and
inspected the home sorry
so that is preventing winners curse for
time being that not make it easy to get
offers a final offers from them you can
get a market advertising offer from them
so what is we are doing so we think that
the risk is where the theory can come
into play so we allow we don't take the
market risk we said that the market is
the best arbitrator of pricing the home
so take the home to the market we create
an option mechanism find the price of
the home but then they we take the
performance risk whenever the buyers and
sellers agree on a price it is our
responsibility to make sure the
transaction will go through you as a
seller can sleep well you don't have to
worry about about the transaction
anymore and these are some of the data
we have in the traditional industry only
95 percent of the 95 percent of the
transactions succeed five percent
actually fail for various reason
in our platform less than 1% transaction
failed out of a thousand transaction we
have done fewer than 10 have failed so
no failure rate and why is it the case
why we can reduce the cost etc so you
know when you have when you take the
responsibility of the risk and you're
only letting the buyers negotiate the
price what do you get you get a very
simple user experience because all you
have to do when you come to our website
you have visited the home you want to
buy all you have to do is tell us how
much you value the home and then we will
do a second price auction so we will not
share that number with the other side if
we say I price I value the home $800,000
we will not tell the other side that
that is what if you entered in fact we
keep it cryptid into the system even I
get I cannot get to know that you
entered $800,000 but it will be if there
is somebody else bid it it will be
approximated higher there very similar
to an auction but you don't have to
worry about writing the terms and
conditions of the transactions like you
know your offer is subject to sun rising
from west tomorrow you don't have to say
any such thing okay so and then we have
I can just show a comparison so this is
the data published by right wind so they
try to copy us without knowing the
theory without having the expertise in
this room so they try to copy us so they
ask 55 difficult questions which most
buyers cannot and they ran an experiment
in Boston where they allow buyers to bid
homes without having professional agent
and out of 127 homes they got off only 5
homes sold through online and 80% of our
home sells online and if we compare just
the direct
direct bias means where the buyers did
not use an agent so there was additional
3% savings we sold 24 homes to direct
buyers from our first 127 homes so this
is a little bit older data but I want
you to give exact comparison so let me
give you a product demo like how we do
the e-commerce and then the most
interesting demo will be the buyers demo
like how buyers make an offer and how we
run the second price auction well let
let me give the context like there are
things we do on the seller side do to
enable that offer so little salads in
your home has never been easier thank
you here in the state of the art online
platform to get started to do this just
click the green get started button on
our home page enter your name the
address of the property you're selling
and confirm the location to save your
listing and access the Fair dashboard
you need to sign in using one of the
four sign-in options nobody sign in that
Farrah
never sees any of your personal
information except name and email
address now you've created your
dashboard next you need to choose your
service level fare a free we get all
these centers we do this your home or
Caroline then you can have a dedicated
agent for this one percent either way
your home will be listed on the local
MLS once you decided on your service
so just confirm your legal name and
assign ourselves contract then you've
got full access to the network on the
left hand side of the dashboard you'll
see that checklist and to-do items
clicking lease link to walk me all the
essential steps to get your home listed
for vendor scheduling you can choose the
times that work for you to have home
photos and inspection perform additional
property for listing paperwork our team
will send you all the necessary
documents you need to give this dick and
when they're done they'll appear in the
documents tab in the Photos tab you can
rearrange any photos aren't redundant or
up lose immediately then on our dynamic
pricing page you can see how that asking
prices are ugly affects your bottom line
in real time
relaxed steps you can send an offer you
may write your home description and
schedule an open house all through the
dashboard once the checklist is finished
we'll give you a final chance for you
but stay with the portsmen etiquette and
that's it now you're active on the
market when awkward starts coming on
home accepted one is just a click away
okay so that was the Celeste I will
their few things we did there it is hard
to notice if you are you you're not an
active sellers first the entire
experience was online then things which
can be built from game theory point of
view many customers is asking for a
vendor the pricing like who the vendor
should be can be based on an auction the
lowest quality vendor sorry highest
quality vendor at the lowest price so
the system can account for it currently
does not it just goes by the but he was
presenting yesterday it goes by the
sequential auction that's it like they
do in the real in advertising so it
sends a order to a first priority vendor
and then the vendor can have yes or no
if we check then the system send in the
second priority vendor and so on and
these vendors come and do the their work
like inspection and photographers
so currently but we have a static
pricing there's no intelligence built in
into the offer we make to them like but
this is now important one where you will
see second prize auction the bidding
from how them how to make an offer to
buy a home so the one important thing in
the in the second by the auction is the
transparency so you need to see the
description as much as possible in the
traditional world in the rest of the
other companies what they do is they
hide the information about the home so
there is a principle in economics called
linkage principle which says that you
maximize your sale price of expectedly
if you share the information here they
hide the information even the legally
required information such as sellers
disclosure why'd you hide the
information because they use that
information to acquire new clients so if
you go to let's say 0 website or redfin
website or anything you will see a
catalog of forms but you cannot do
anything with it
because they want you to contact them
about the transaction about assisting
they are trying to get you but if you go
to our website you can see the seller
disclosure and everything which helps
you make the right bed whatever you
believe you value the home so that's a
important differentiation and that's
actually required for any kind of a
auction or any kind of a pricing
mechanism
so let me show you that how this happens
making an offer a fair home is simple
and takes as little as two minutes in
this step-by-step video will show you
now once you've identified the home you
want to make an offer on start out by
reviewing the information like melissa
page you can find quick facts about the
home here and fairs exclusive
transparency reports here transparency
reports can include an inspection report
a title report and any other information
you may find valuable before making your
offer if there are any standing offers
on the property you can see that here
once you're ready to get started on your
offer just click the green make an offer
button at the top of the page on the
next screen you'll need to sign in using
one of the four available on calendar
fighters Google Microsoft Yahoo or
Facebook I'm going to sign into Google a
note when you log in that era never sees
any of your personal information next
confirm that your contact information is
correct and if so click continue to
start out your offer
first choose if you're a real estate
agent making an offer for a plant or a
direct fire if you're a direct fire you
can make the offer on your own or have a
Ferro broker assist you next enter the
full legal names of all buyers and their
contact information if you're buying in
the name of an LLC or a trust you can
enter on this optional escalation if you
enter an escalation is kept completely
private from the seller next accept the
terms and conditions of the fair
platform lastly to ensure that your
offer is genuine you'll need to make a
$500 poll on the credit card please note
that this hole will not be fully charged
unless you're a perceptive if your offer
is accepted the $500 will be paid
the balance at the platform which takes
the place of - money finally your credit
card is processed securely by stripe one
of the world's most trusted credit card
processors it's never seen before kept
on file by Farah and that's it your
offer has been submitted to the seller
and is now so this is backing view so
what you saw we only ask one question
besides of court rebuilding what's your
name my property or buying this is
already so we are only asked one
question how much you want to pay for
this home there's nothing we asked and
it's so the system is working with 99%
success and why does it work 99% success
did anybody notice that a card so we
have we used a sunk cost so there is a
credit card number on file not with us
with stripe and if the offer is accepted
they are committed right there so they
are not negotiating the terms of the
sale and most buyers and sellers are not
anyway are capable of negotiating in
terms of the sale sure please whatever I
do with the stripe credit card thing
right and if I put in an offer for
750,000 that obliges me to pay that 750
doesn't do that the credit card can
enforce no the guy come you know which
had you $500 yeah
so this $500 basically makes sure that -
you are committed to purchase because
you are not making random offers yes but
nobody wants to voluntary lose $500
either this is another another thing we
learned at eBay that most of the fraud
happens by professional fraud you don't
have to worry about individuals the
professional fraud happens if they can
repeat it multiple times
there's no way to repeat multiple times
so most people are not committing fraud
they are genuinely making an offer and
if they are not committed to it they
will lose that $500 so in the behind the
scene what happens is
the system is taking into account
various attributes because different
offers could be slightly different even
though we asked very little information
for example you have an agent or not if
you were working with an agent the
system asked you one this question then
your dollar will be accounted as if 97
cents because you giving a dollar but
then you brought a person who will be
taking 3 cents back out of that so the
system will account for that you might
be asking for loans assistance and all
those things so they will the system
will account for all of that the system
does not account yet for the failure
probability and one reason it is not
accounting for its it's 99% success what
is any person failure happens you you
got into a home you said I am going to
buy the home on September 15th
that's your closing date and then your
lender your bank tells we don't want to
give you this much loan then you cannot
buy the home anymore so that's a failure
it's not catastrophic failure by the
catastrophic failure for climb because
the client it is the black or white now
you were moving to another town you
cannot like you have this obligation you
cannot buy your next home you cannot
move on with your life so the failure
it's much more significant for the
seller and one way you can attribute the
value of this failure most sellers are
willing to take two to five percent
lower offer if it were a cash offer so
if you make eight and a thousand dollar
offer and nickle make a seven ninety but
all cash the seller is likely to take
his offer even those ten thousand dollar
lower so that is the you can estimate
the value of failure in seller's mind by
looking at these data which in terms of
contract so we provide the inspection
report already so there's an inspection
note report provided and you are
supposed to take that into account in
your offer okay so if you think that the
kitchen requires ten thousand dollars
and you be the judge know the buyer you
can take that into account and make an
offer accordingly very good so we have a
two step commitment protocol so what
happens in in the traditional scenario
when you commit only the seller comments
the buyer is actually not committing
because buyers has this cop out like
right to inspect the kitchen okay so so
in that case the seller is committed and
this is this causes the moral hazard and
it is and you won't believe it what
fraction of industry practice model
hazard it's non negligible so model
hazard is the thing you go into a
contract by offering a price which you
never intended to pay you always believe
that you know I got into contract now
this home will be taken off the market
but since only the seller is making
commitment as a buyer I'm not making a
commitment I can come back and ask the
seller to readjust the price that's a
moral hazard and the sellers is and I
can do so because I have nothing to lose
you know if I just try to and the seller
is already lost something in this
transaction because the sellers home is
publicly told to the world it is sold
for 800 K now I come back and I say hey
like you know I looked at the kitchen I
changed my mind I can offer you only 780
now what will happen now sellers have
two bad choices he
offer your 780 or say that you know I'm
going back to the market but when you go
back to the market the market is going
to discount it knowing that one buyer
already rejected the home for one reason
so we prevent moral hazard by providing
the inspection of friend so in the
two-step commitment product process all
the information we have is provided a
friend the buyer make a soft commitment
by putting only $500 and it is covered
by our money back policy just like on
Amazon you buy things there is a
transaction failure on Amazon also
because you got the product you say I
don't like it then they have a certain
policies to defend your money similarly
we have a certain policy we say that if
you just change your mind for no reason
you lose that five million dollars so
that means its seller sorry a buyer
cannot enter a false number and try to
renegotiate because that would have a
cost of $500 but if you perform your
inspection etc by professionals we want
to see the receipts etc which usually
cost five hundred two thousand dollars
then we will refund it but again you had
spent you cannot renegotiate the
transaction what you can do so is you do
your inspection you decide you know I
did my inspection I didn't like the home
the home goes back into the market but
it was but goes back into the market in
the sense that we allow on our website
offers from other buyers but we never
have taken the home off the market in
the first place so after you have done
your inspection etc once you are sure
that the kitchen is what it should be
for you at that point you pay us our
total fee our total fee is half percent
that's it so you pay out half percent
that is when the buyers and sellers
commit so it's a simultaneous commitment
at that point the buyer does not have
right to cancel the transaction
all the variables and that the buyers
control the statistically transaction
may still fail which is less than 1% but
the buyer cannot cause the failure
anymore without losing the half percent
and from our point of view whether
people half person you usually like to
$3,000 nobody wants to lose to $3,000
they don't plan a strategy where they
could be at a loss of two three thousand
dollars yes yeah so we we sell all kind
of homes newer orders in hot market
since we are ecommerce we sell homes
2,000 miles away from where we live a
very good question
so in our pocket and sale agreement
let's say hey the question if you have a
self-driving car which you have a dry
out seatbelt for the driver no because
there is no driver
so contingencies apply to the deposit
unless money we don't have any deposit
we change so the the earnest money
notion like the traditional processes if
you and I agree to do a transaction I
would send ten thousand dollars into an
escrow account and then we write a
40-page contract to decide who is going
to get ten thousand dollars if that if
the transaction fails do I going to get
back or does it go to the seller so this
is and all the terms and condition has
typically written in a way that the
buyer is going to get that $10,000 back
in our case we don't have that deposit
so if your mortgage fail you had paid
zero deposit will give you zero back so
you have a full right as a buyer to not
continue the transaction you can drop it
so in some sense you have all the
contingencies in the world including the
Sun rising from the West which doesn't
happen by the way yeah so so you can
have all the contingencies
you want the thing which you have paid
is our technology fee which is not part
of the home price these technology fee
is determined only by our money back
policy and our money back policy says
that if your loan is declined because
the home was not valued by the lender we
will return it to you our half person
but again that's not a variable in
buyers control unless you can bribe
which doesn't happen in at least in this
country bribe the appraiser but if the
loan fails because you lost job or your
own lender made you a false pre-approval
letter which they didn't make then you
lose it's your responsibility to make
sure that you had a job isn't nothing to
do with the seller it's your
responsibility to make sure that your
lender is reliable you lose the half
person in that case yes it's happened
all on the website it's happening in
real time these are time stamps which is
$1,000 also you are bidding agreement we
fix it to one thousand dollars you can
bet any number of times so you can
either use the automated system proxy
bidding you tell us the explanation
amount our system will bid it for you or
you can come back yourself you can bid
as many times as possible as you want
not who what it is the number is shown
and these numbers if you see these
numbers are not exactly the number typed
by the client
these numbers are computed in your
perspective so as an example look at
this 740 number okay let's say you
didn't
have an agent so if you click this
button here I don't have an agent
then this 7:40 when is translated in
your domain will become roughly 718 so
you will see only 718 this is not
necessarily you so you are not learning
the confidential information of the
competing buyer whether they have an
agent or not you don't get to learn that
I tell you hack you can learn about it
but see being recorded so I can tell you
later
this is this is again a very good
question
so here the you're in California I
believe we live here in Seattle we
actually traditional market also
practice sort of a second price auction
but here is the second price auction
goes there and and actually I bought my
home and that's inspired the company
here the second price auction goes in
the in the traditional so you send a
contract which says that I am making a
$700,000 offer escalating up to eight
hundred thousand dollars and you sign it
as a buyer that contract is sent to the
seller the contract says that if the
seller has whatever offer let's say
seller got 750 offer you say that any
offer will be increased by letter five
thousand euros so then your offer
automatically becomes 755 but the seller
gets 780 your offer becomes a variable
you send this contract to the seller
first of all it's your signature only
seller never agree to all those terms
you are sending a contract with your
signature and you are giving a number to
the seller but your maximum bid now what
do you think the second highest bid will
be
in traditional contract exactly it
almost always happens there's a second
highest bid because you have given so if
you are given your number without having
interested auctioneer or platform in
between the sellers agent is going to
get you unless they already have an
offer like that they are going to get
there another offer which is 795 no
seller is going to willingly sell you at
740 knowing that you are willing to pay
up to 800 in fact the way it is written
your contract in Seattle the second
price auction it cannot even decide
whether the the actual competing buyer
is even capable of buying because it's a
vague notion whether he can so in fact
you can go to a traffic light find a
homeless person there give a $20 say
that can you make an offer for 795 I
need to escalate this and this is
perfectly legal he's can legally make an
offer for 795 it is practical of whether
he can buy it or not and and that's why
the escalation happens now in our system
there's no there's no risk-free way for
the sellers to up because 800k is first
of all kept confidential so if a seller
tries to make a higher offer a tell his
friend to make an higher offer the
seller is taking the following risk his
friend may end up winning the home use
it but then your offer is drawn if his
friends offer exceeded at the end of the
day the escalation you have is in your
mind the maximum escalation it's even if
you enter in our system it will be kept
confidential
first price without a transparency that
the heavy force assessment of the home
price based on full speed you know but
that doesn't happen because this is the
false but we have noticed it doesn't
happen on our platform so first of all
there's a credit card involved and then
the second thing is the friend like if
you try to enter the false bid you don't
have the bit of the real buyer so if you
enter the false bit what would happen we
were taking a risk of showing a very
genuine buyer so you can always if you
believe your home was worth more than
765 you can reject this offer and you
tell to the world no I believe my home
is 790 you can set your listing price
SMI 90 so given the false bed we looked
at our data very carefully if we have
any suspicions anytime we do verify we
call the buyer or biased broker and we
have zero instances of false pet at
least we haven't observed any we have
observed one behavior though very well
let's say you are a direct bar you
didn't have an agent there is a very
strong and anchor effect we have seen
let's say you jumped at this thing it
just not winning
you saw the 765 price okay you saw
somebody is willing to buy 765 and you
don't have an agent so you click this
button here then that 765 I think will
be 742 or something or you say ho you
can save 23 so you come back and you you
you make an offer for 743 you know what
is the escalation you put where is the
human 765 so you put the 743 you try to
carry this and then you put 765 as your
escalation amount so effectively what
you have done is and now the original
buyer who had an agent when he comes to
the page if you you will see the number
as
a thousand higher than here and they may
both start competing at some point
effectively the Commission savings which
the buyers have is translated into
winning the home rather than translated
in like the the seller is still like
paying like we have a plan for free the
seller is still not paying us any
information so the it's because of the
anchor effect the savings gets
translated back in to put sellers
so these are some of the things we
already talked about why it works so the
linkage principle there is a social
validation which we observed like all
the time like you a direct bar comes
they look at all the existing bed and
they make a higher offer
so social validation we actually I want
that by the way eBay as a researcher we
noticed even there also there are papers
you will find in in scientific journals
where you will see doctor
if you start your auction at a lower
price then your eventual price is higher
then if you try to guess the best price
for your good because what happens is
like people see their like other people
are valuing that good and they start
like keep bidding and maybe they certain
entertainment value may be certain ego
hey I need to win this this and this
thing are on eBay but we we see that
social validation playing out here
especially when the buyers don't have an
agent and of course these are the this
is revelation principle this is
essentially saying second prize option
and the low friction is also that a
traditional method it takes about two if
you have a professional agent with you
it takes about half a day two full day
to prepare an offer so many people they
don't want to do that so you actually
see fewer offers in the traditional
system so if you go with the traditional
agent because the buyer side when they
see ok it's not worth about putting so
much effort and what happens is the
system has learnt a very bad attribute
which we have to face also that if a
seller says I'm going to sell my home
for eight hundred thousand dollars let's
say Don was not really what they
attended then what buyers do buy us just
wait they are trained to wait they are
not making an offer
we want that no matter how low you think
the home is well make an offer there's
no ego issue here it's just a system
just come and make an offer even if you
believe the home is just one dollar just
express your bid so in the traditional
system they don't express four to three
reasons one is of course it takes effort
the second there is a notion of
reputation among the agents it's like we
are all peers who are in a part of a
single community agents are also a part
of a single community they feel that
sending a lowball offer is an insult to
the listing agent you are telling that
hey you are fooled to put this property
at 800 K it's really worth 600 so
because of those reputation risk the
market does not have an efficient
mechanism to correct a price on the
lower direction so if you list a home at
a high price the only way it will be
corrected is by weight if you list a
home at a lower price then the market
has mechanism to correct it quickly so
if let's say you don't know the future
your home is can be worth 700 K or 900 K
who knows but if you shoot at a higher
price the seller that's then what you
have done is you have shoo away a lot of
your potential buyers most of the buyers
who are going to be interested in your
home comes in the first two weeks and
you must list it at a low price to
maximize the number of buyers who pays
attention to your home if a let's say at
a high price then all you have done is
basically shorten your buyer pool and
that actually has negatively affect
negatively your home sale both in terms
of eventual price and also in terms of
timing you the set around
so we already talked about that like how
it works here so the other things which
is like by the failure rate is so low
that is we observe there is a regret or
buyer's remorse minimization going on
and I think that is a multiple reasons
for it one is the more information the
buyers have the second is the buyer's
remorse usually come from when the
intended system when buyers and sellers
go than the contract the next day buyers
the next day probably biases not
sleeping worried about you know whether
he make the right decision and the next
morning he weighs maybe he paid too much
but here it doesn't happen because you
know that if you had offered a thousand
less you would not have gotten the home
so you did not so there is a and B proof
you get that you have the you're paying
the right price of course there's the
sunk cost commitment we talked about
that they pay the this half percent at
the time of contract signing one
question then you can ask is how do we
get buyers to pay some cost because
buyers are also reads covers how can
they pay the son cause the reason is
like we have a very very generous
different policies and we have
essentially done the surgery of a
transaction where we remove the moral
hazard from our different policy but
everything else we have covered like you
for most reasons if you cannot buy the
home your money will be refunded except
when you just change your mind
so we do not cover failures which bias
could have controlled so that is also
one thing I want to mention that we have
a lot of data about our home
transactions and I think one of the
things which our rough and now's a show
is we get about
ah 2% higher price excluding the savings
with the savings the sellers get even
better return and then we also looked at
the homes because we don't sell all the
homes we the homes which failed to close
on our platform then probably you will
go and list with a traditional method
and then we notice what's happening to
those transactions and in 95% of the
cases the those home sells for at least
$30,000 lower so it shows that when
homes fail to salam on our platform it
is primarily for one reason and that
reason is the the price expectation of
this seller we cannot control that but
eventually the seller goes to another
broker and we can see at that time so so
these are the data point which can
actually increase if anybody wants to
study so we can under NDA can share our
data in a non private way like we cannot
share the names etc for our consumers
but the page that's anyways on our
website so but rather than looking at
yourself we can give you as a nice
package all this data and you can
analyze and and see if these principles
are actually helping and that will be an
independent claim rather than me making
this claim
Rick
[Applause]
how you like whenever you create a new
platform there's this issue of getting
both sides to come so it is a solved
problem in the United States there is
something called MLS so even if you have
single home to sell you are independent
broker you can advertise home to all the
pretty much and a person of your market
so you just put your home enter into MLS
database it will show up on Zillow
redfin everywhere actually I have not
known such an efficient system in any
other industry which can market the
goods you are selling to almost hundred
percent of your potential buyer so
another thing which I didn't go through
so our system is backward compatible
this is one of the things we have done
and so you can enter offer online
yourself or you can send a traditional
paper offer paper means like a paper
like PDF file that's the so you can send
or you can even fax it with me but we
don't care in that case so we are
running a simultaneous auction which is
both online and offline and this is a
was a very difficult thing to do and I
know at eBay so not everybody probably
know here but just a piece of
information
eBay has a real estate license in all 50
states okay but you don't sell your home
on eBay okay but they do they they are
licensed to do so so eBay try to work
with other like offline auction scenario
that you can submit offer online and
offline and I know that it's very
difficult to synchronize these two
things so in our platform so the rules
on your off lines offer which we call it
are governed by the contract the
prepared by the buyer and rules of the
online offer is governed by our terms
and
so we create a competition even between
these two scenario so it's totally
backward compatible that's another way
so it's a buyers choice they can make an
offer online or they can submit an
offline offer so here are some data so I
think over 80% of our offers are online
especially in the case where the home
was priced correctly and there multiple
offers if the home was priced
incorrectly like the seller is asking
too much money incorrectly means that
and it's not in a hot area then the
buyer's agent tried to show their skills
okay I can for my client I can show my
skills and try to get you a better price
then they do not use it because they try
to utilize all these loopholes to try to
negotiate better price but otherwise
most of them do submit online offers so
it is a voluntary so customers don't
have to trust you they can always submit
online so you're offline offer so it's
it's completely voluntary so the trust
comes from being in the market for a
long time and not do the wrong things to
the customers so again like again the
leverage if the home is priced correctly
it's a hot area then buyers will trust
because they feel that by following the
instructions given by these sellers
broker without us maximizes their chance
of winning the home but if the home is
not correctly priced and of course the
leverage goes to the buyer side then
they they voluntarily choose whether
they want to trust or not there is a
benefit door for submitting online so if
they submit an offer online everything
is processed automatically the contact
is written automatically by the website
it can create contract binding contracts
and but if they send an offline offer
then we have to manually work so that's
not free so in that case we are going to
charge a fee from the seller so the
effective price for the seller is lower
so if you send to an offer offline
either you are trading your chances of
victories at home or you are paying a
little bit extra to cover up the manual
cost you are in causing on the other end
etc go so we don't yet have like a
flexible communication which happens in
private over the phone so one of the
things I want to say ecommerce always
have a physical layer like an even when
you buy it right on Hoover there is a
physical car come saying a UPS truck
comes in wind so physically the buyer is
going to visit the home so there is a
offline communication which we cannot
control and here is something we want to
train our sellers so one of the causes
sometime happens as humans are humans
they have four personalities and all
sometimes they cause friction with each
other so one of the role for broker is
the relationship management and act as a
buffer where there is no ego clash
happens between the buyer and sellers
there are other things we have done on
our platform too so one of the issue in
case of consumer Commerce is
discrimination so there is of course
equal housing law but people are people
still it's a it's a problem for
companies like uber or Airbnb or food
companies so in not necessarily in this
country in other places so we have made
a very like early on principle that we
will not implement technologies which
will allow people to discriminate but we
would not police them either so in their
home
like we are not placed they are doing
whatever they are doing but on the
platform so some of the restrictions we
have come from is we don't enable so as
an example we do not allow sellers to
choose the offer we choose this is the
best offer for you you if you don't like
it you are welcome to take the offer
offline but on the platform this is the
best offer there is no reason for you to
discriminate against this highest and
best offer
[Applause]